so we know that the executive branch of
the government essentially had their
boot on the neck of these people at
Twitter
um and to their credit what I observed
over and over again at Twitter took
almost in every instance were people who
were genuinely struggling and debating
about what to do so the system you
described I think was was flawed but
when the people were having
conversations about this they oftentimes
pushed back against the government these
were these were people who were doing
the best they could I think and they
weren't sure you know under the
directives given to them either by the
you know people at the top of Twitter or
you know indirectly by the government
and I've heard some people say well the
government's just asking I mean that is
an incredibly
um naive position to take about how the
world functions